[Music]
when all
hope seems lost
when heroes are needed more than
ever our
fate is in there pause
a dog actually sir i'm a puppy
that's even worse you're in shock so i'm
not gonna take that personally
this summer another perfect rescue the
worldwide phenomenon
will be unleashed on the big screen
paw patrol what's your emergency my name
is liberty we need your help
humdinger he's going to destroy
adventure
come on pups adventure city's in trouble
[Music]
welcome to our new headquarters this
is so cool there's even a new and
improved pup treat dispenser
what it's a beautiful thing
no dog by order of the new mayor he's
more of a cat person
ladies and gentlemen and most
importantly influencers with over 10 000
followers
[Music]
we've got to rescue those people let's
get to work
paw patrol is on a roll are you
kidding me i got this get out of the way
move you got to know how to talk to
people
now go let's pick the tires and fight
some fires cowboys
[Music]
drone
[Music]
yikes
[Music]
you